Andrew Tate Andrew Tate to entertain
Ed while Andrew Tate was arrested in his
home
addressed last night no criminal charges
have been filed now we're worried so
it's been 10 months they still have not
been charged
me
there's no evidence in my files I've
done nothing wrong neither me nor
batteries are victims in this case there
are no victims in this case and I am not
a victim
I think you were the last interview of
Tate before you went to jail he gets
women into this like mind state where
they're very much into him what's
happening is they had nine months to
investigate and they wired capture the
brothers they were looking at their
private Communications they had the
witness statements of the women they had
psychological reports he basically has
like this cam girl Sweatshop set up in
their basement where he's got all these
women working defrauding them on their
taxes and stealing money from them so
were the girls free to leave the whole
time
what he said he did in his videos he is
a hamburger full stop well you can never
have a scenario where you basically
detain someone and take away someone's
Liberty and then investigate and try and
find the evidence I'm putting myself in
these girls shoes I get a boyfriend
right and the boyfriend convinces me to
do cam work that was my decision that's
great that you think that that's
personal decisions
you cannot cut me off like I'm just
tired we're gonna blame the men for your
poor decision